the reason a lot of people are freaking
out is because one he's putting his
thumb on the scale by saying he is more
likely to vote Republican he's showing
himself to be center right and sort of
just having a political opinion versus
being this amorphous thing that doesn't
have a political opinion
um I think if if I were to guess I
haven't talked to him about it but if I
were to guess he's sending a kind of
signal that's important for the Twitter
the company itself because if we're
being honest most of the employees are
left-leaning so you have to kind of send
a signal that like a resisting mechanism
to say like uh since most of the
employees are left is is good for uh for
Elon to be more right to balance out the
way the actual engineering is done to
say we're not going to do any kind of
activism activism inside the engineering
if if I were to guess that's kind of the
effective
aspect of that of that mechanism and the
other one by posting the Pelosi thing is
probably to expand the Overton window
like saying we can play we can post
stuff we could post conspiracy theories
and then through discourse figure out
what is and isn't true